pour moi la chose la plus difficile de
vraiment des réussir en plus de gens
jeunes comme nous deux de faire une vie
ensemble une vie une vraie vie à côté de
ce métier c'est important que le métier
oui pour moi oui c'est bien un moment où
ça peut s'arrêter surtout pour pour une
femme un jour on est plus jeune on est
plus joli et puis si ça s'arrête on a
plus rien si on n'a pas quelqu'un ou une
vie ou un con ou on peut aller ou un
enfant
j'ai quelque chose au-dessus de ce
métier et je m'accroche bien et je sais
je vais me garder effectivement d'avoir
quelque chose dans sa vie qui nous
nourrissent et qui nous permettent de
nous réparer aussi des coûts que l'on
prend dans ce métier entre les films il
faut justement vivre il faut justement
aimer il faut se renouir de beaucoup de
choses cette partie entre les films dans
la vie privée est essentiel
[Musique]